[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight last night we played our
interview with President Trump from
Helsinki part of that interview has made
headlines today people are upset about
it has nothing by the way to do with
Vladimir Putin or Mother Russia it has
to with a nation of Montenegro which by
the way smaller than the state of
Connecticut Montenegro has fewer
residents than the District of Columbia
it's a relatively poor place it has no
critical natural resources and limited
strategic significance few Americans
could find it on a map or name its
capital or its president that's not a
slur against Montenegro apparently it's
a nice place but those are the facts
about Montenegro from an American
perspective it's not an important
country and yet suddenly because of an
act of Congress that few people noticed
Montenegro has profound significance to
every American since last year
Montenegro has been a member of the NATO
alliance that means that if Montenegro
ever finds itself in a war our military
is pledged to defend it
that's called a defense guarantee
defence guarantees don't seem like a big
deal until suddenly they are that's how
the first world war started
37 million casualties later the world
began to rethink the wisdom of treaties
like that but the lesson seems to have
been lost since in our interview with
President Trump in Finland we thought it
might be worth having a conversation or
starting one about America's obligations
to NATO so we asked a simple question
why is it in our interest to defend the
territorial integrity of Montenegro why
should our soldiers fight and die on its
behalf here's the exchange we had
membership in NATO
obligates the members to defend any
other member that's attacked so let's
say Montenegro it's joined last year's
attack why should my son go to
Montenegro to defend it from attack why
is that what you're saying I've asked
the same question you know Montenegro is
a tiny country with very strong people
yeah I'm not against one right where
Albania by the way they have very strong
people they have very aggressive people
they may get aggressive and
congratulations you're in World War 3
now I understand that but that's the way
it was set up so that's not a definitive
answer obviously but the president
clearly had been
thinking about it and good for him
presidents are supposed to wonder about
things like that serious countries ought
to have debates like that the US has to
defend Montenegro really why is that is
there a good reason let's hear it that's
the conversation we should be having but
the guardians of our public conversation
are not serious people they are hacks
and buffoons for wondering about our
defense guarantee with Montenegro Trump
is being denounced for treason for
asking the question
we're accused of taking orders from
Vladimir Putin one of the Russians have
on Tucker Carlson asked a longtime CNN
star Kathy Griffin
a former network did an entire segment
this afternoon suggesting that Americans
somehow have some sort of moral
obligation to lay down their lives for
Montenegro here's part of it yet again
raising serious doubts about whether he
would honor article 5 of the NATO
charter if it came down to it it's a
cornerstone of the Alliance an armed
attack on one nation is an attack on all
this time the president questioned
whether the United States should honor
its agreement when it comes to NATO's
newest member Montenegro so the argument
apparently is that because Montenegro
has about 20 non-combatants in
Afghanistan right now we the US has an
eternal obligation to spend American
money and lives defending montenegro's
borders that is idiotic which is to say
perfect for cable news in real life a
defense guarantee is not something you'd
enter into lightly
it's like promising a friend to take
care of his kids if he dies it's a
solemn commitment and you would not make
it unless you plans to keep it so the
question is do we plan to keep it do we
really plan to defend Montenegro or many
of the other NATO members how about
Estonia how about Slovakia you ready to
have your kids die in those countries
the US government is ready to send them
we've promised to do that NATO was
created almost 70 years ago for a
specific and noble purpose keeping the
Soviets from invading Western Europe it
worked
thank God but the Soviet Union no longer
exists and it hasn't existed for almost
30 years
NATO meanwhile is still around and it's
getting bigger why is that and more to
the point is it serving America's
interests or
imperiling them those are vital
questions official Washington does not
want to answer them or talk about them
they're trying to crush anyone who asks
we are not intimidated obviously